so I was just talking to Colton okay so
that's great but I got interrupted by by
who
what's her name one who brought the dogs
oh wait Catherine interrupted I walked
away and he said fourth time's the charm
for time that is unheard of I think
everyone should get a chance at time
talk to everyone so and I told her that
what the hell I can't believe she's sold
Puma getting like I thought we had a
great conversation we hugged it out
afterwards and everything but obviously
she doesn't care at all four times is a
little bit excess it's a little
excessive for sure not even a little
like excessive it's actually excessive
it's really frustrating because I have
been waiting patiently and being
respectful to all the other girls to get
my time and Catherine is just being
straight up rude how is it possible that
someone can enter up so many times
already there's so many people in
government right a lot of girls have not
talked to him yet so they're starting to
panic oh my gosh
because you don't get time you're
probably going home
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]